It's LWIAY time! That's my intro that's my new intro
Grab your favorite G fuel and let's freakin do this
*Pewds drinking G Fuel*
I've seen this fan art and it's goddamn perfect. Thank you so much Buffalo pillow
Me and the boys ready to give the news without Poppy Gloria
Is it me or is Poppy Gloria fusing into some sort of monster?
Oh, Okay. Wait. Sir Pelo did the art is that right? Oh, it's Pelo that did it. Ah, that's not a retweet.
I love it
I uncovered the mystery of pewdiepie's window cleaner. What? The truth can never be stopped Felix Oh
Our dear PewDiePie thinks he's so smart - you're goddamn right - by not showing the brand of his window cleaner
*PFFFFFFFFFFF*
I'm a stalker, Felix!
Challenge accep- What the hell is this? First: analyze the footage. Blue part, white part
Curvy bottle, blue liquid. What is this? Let's google blue window cleaning spray.No, that's not it
Nope
Windex nope
Ajax actually spray. Oh, oh
Bottle shape matches but not the color. Oh gosh. Let's analyze the logo
Come on, I literally showed the logo!
100% Red colour
First letter is W. Hmm
Best match so far is Windolene
Let's Google their products... Oh God. Oh God no...
And boom!
You think you had me figured out huh? So yeah, you have too much spare time. Congratulations, you did it!
It doesn't even look like that. Wake up sheeple idiots. Poppy Gloria is still alive? You're sleeping? Yeah
What if Poppy Gloria killed Mary Ham and then disguised herself as Mary Ham to avoid suspicions?
Bruh -  Wait, what if Poppy Gloria killed Matt Hamm and then disguised herself as Mary Ham? Oh my god the plot
Now this is impressive, first the windows stuff and now this you guys should become detectives or something Jesus Christ. This is beautiful
Goddamit
I wish this is real so much. Is this real? Yes, of course it is.  huge video quality
Pewds' video quality
Okay, here we go again.
Marzia's video quality
This meme is never gonna die, isn't it? (No pewds) Here I have the perfect quality and people still complain
Shaking my head my head. He's dead. One like equals five push-ups, please. I really need this. Haha
What is that oh it's
49,000 Jesus Christ what is that, 250,000?
That's not too bad. It's gonna be fucking rip, dude
He's gonna have abs on top of his abs. Now. This is some original content! What... Mr Beast uploaded this?
L ast to stop kissing wince 25 grand challenge. Jesus Christ, dude. It'd be fun even Mr. Beast did this
Try the Russian Roulette challenge
With six bullets in the gun. Okay. Alright, okay
Let's calm down. Planted a bunch about nine hundred little trees in this pasture. It ain't much but it's honest work
Well done soldier
Well done. This channel will keep going in 50 years and we'll do an update then update on the trees. That's amazing, i like that.
Keep planting trees goddamnit. What are you doing right now? Stop wasting your time on cleaners and start planting trees goddamnit
My friend recently passed and he was a huge fan of pewdiepie
This is a video of him back when the T-Series thing was big. I hope to honor him by getting him onto LWIAY (You did it Bro.)
I Don't like you mr. T nothing personal kid. Sorry to hear by you, bro
Apple announces 99 Hund-
Oh, yeah, Jesus Christ, a thousand dollar monitor stand the Chinese guy who made him for $0.12
Absolutely incredible. What, you don't want a stand that looks like a cheese grater? Whaat?
Why does it cost a thousand though? Honestly, like what?
What is it made of, gold? Very true. Scientists: students need - I see where this is going
Need a full eight hours of sleep schools. We don't do that here. They need homework
You see they can't just do
Schoolwork at school. They need to also do schoolwork at home
Oh, weekends when there's no school. Oh, nono. I went to a Montessori School, which is based on the concept that you're supposed to
Study yourself at school like we got an hour a day in school for us to do homework and stuff like that
But that just led to teachers giving us more homework because we always go
hey, there's no time for us to do the homework and they're like
Oh is there I believe that is an hour every day every teacher went that
So we - school sucks
Smash like if you think school sucks, too
School didn't even teach me how to buy a Lambo like smh man. PewDiePie deserves proper recognition. Oh, that's goddamn right okay?
2019's YouTube rewind will be worse than 2018's - why? - Since YouTube will most likely have something related to T-Series but not pewds
*Pewds realizing he's doomed*
That hurts, man. You guys think of everything, don't you? And that's a fact. That's alright we'll put Grandayy, Dolan and Kitty together
It won't matter
Explanation time. She's like the best. She's my favorite. I love Mary ham. Alright, let's hear it. Now. This is Christ's
PewDiePie actually killed Poppy Gloria because he has a crush on mary ham *laughters*
No, I just think she's kind of hot, ok?
Sure, say what you want about her, but you cannot deny the fact that Mary Ham looks hella sexy. Hold on. What about Marzia?
Okay. Alright, let's calm down. Let's remind Felix of this. We want the story! After my balls healed, I broke my peepee.
One day I'll tell you about it. This is a lie. I never broke my peepee,
Reported - So weird that this group is interested in this man's genitalia. Whaat?
Me posting only half the meme. Yeah. Okay. I got it.
Oh my god, is it here? Redditors. My fr- *Felix realizes what actually happened*
*clap*
A plus, that was amazing *laughter*
They're right underneath each other too - that's awesome
Sorry, brother. It needed to be done. When you find out your brother watches morgz. Alright.
So long partner. When i'm with my girl and I see the boys. That's not a girl(?) I'm so confused. Kind of thick though
Did you get a girlfriend? Yes. What did it cost?
The boys. Come on
Come on, as long as you're not Pippi whipped then it's fine
I take your meme and I raise you one IKEA boi.
Normal DNA
Marzia's DNA
Felix's DNA
Oh, it's IKEA. Got it. You think that's funny you blatantly racist.
Look at Marzia's DNA
How could you say this about me?
Mary Ham bad. Oh god. What is it now when the sub to pewds meme ended and I realized I can't change my name
*laughter* Sub to king pewds
Oopsiee! Did Mary ham review you in meme review? Yes. What did it cost? The boys. All of them.
I think this is one of those memes that will stick around. Using the Drake - Goddamnit - Drake formula. I need to review this
f*ckin meme. Sorry, this frickin meme. Using a new template with houses So pewds can get - *laughter*
I Take it back, that's ten out of ten. Thank you
That's funny
Mary Ham promoting a scam app meaning she'll probably get terminated. I can't believe Mary Ham did this. I'm Poppy Gloria all along
All right. Well the next point I guess I have to address this not a meme
but there's a lot of people commenting on pew news recent video and I thought I'd send it here - this got
30,000 up votes and it says don't download Nimses, the app Pewds advertised
It takes all of you data and monitors it even after you uninstall it. Now, this is just demonstrably false, okay?
Apps can't do that if you uninstall it, so it's already spreading misinformation, just in the title.
Literally every single social media tracks the way Nimses does it's a social media app
Everyone seems so freaked out about it
And there was this this top boat saying that they broke down the apk
like the the file on
Android and it showed what it does and the really scary part is that they use the following permissions ordered by danger from high to
Low, the fact that it starts itself when the phone powers on any app that has notifications does this, okay?
What else it requests install packages can request the users to install additional apps and software
Literally any app with ads does this we do it in tuber simulator as well?
Hey
You want to download this other app that we have, PewDiePie legend of the brofist, if you don't want to do it
Just click no.
It Asks you to do all this. Permission to get accounts - literally reads which accounts you are logged into - Google does the same thing
Android permission camera
Whaat? A social media network wants to use my camera? Oh, what do you want, to look at me? Like come on guys
Listen, they're not paying me to defend these allegations
But you're just going off rumors. If you're worried about your privacy by all means don't sign up to a social media network
I thought it sounded like a cool idea. If you guys didn't like the promo and you know, like the sponsorship, I'm sorry
I mean
I will try to do better to find ads that you like but it's also everyone seems so protective of me
My answer was so like, oh we need to protect them from all the media stuff
And then you're spreading misinformation to make it look like I'm promoting a scam
Obviously that makes it look way worse. Same thing with Dlive like Dlive is not a scam
There's no proof to show that, but it's a bunch of rumors spread around being like, oh it's promoting a scam
Again, I have no equity. I have no reason to defend it besides the fact that it's misinformation
I mean how could Mary Ham promote an app like that?
Disgusting! So disappointed in her. She is gonna get fired for sure
Nintendo of America did an Oopsie. Happy Pride Month.
*laughter*
Oh God I wish that was real. But those two are brothers. That can't be real. Happy incest month.
No, that can't be right. Please. Be real
Okay, it is real but it's not their official - *Laughter*
11,000 retweets
Aw my heart - People pointed out how it looks like my arm is just super long
This was my mom's birthday. Wait, so pewds unironically wears that hair style
But
Petition to make pew- YouTube release Scare PewDiePie season 2 at a hundred million. Come on, please Susan (Yeah please)
Pleease. I'll be a good boy, Susan!
An Apple Pro Stand oor... The Chair;
One year worth of G Fuel; All his merch
And bonus thirty dollars to plant some goddamn trees
Girls in science class: Ew I'm not touching a frog Boys in science class: boys in science class!
Our Masterpiece is finished if you're a boy only you can relate. What if we used a hundred percent of our brain?
Passing joggers on my motorized treadmill.
Damn it
YouTube 2019 is literally just amazing thumbnails
You don't even have to watch the video
Felix having more followers than me on all social media me having more karma and ready
Do I have that little karma? Why aren't you giving me karma Goddamnit? Stop crying. She's dead get over it
No one is ever really gone. What is this from? Stop posting Marvel memes, I don't understand them.
Nobody: - *Laughter*
Is this a gif? It is yeah
Elon Musk tall boi - 188
Pewds: 181. Elon can be taller than me. That's fine.
Choose wisely. A chair or Apple Pro Stand? Can I interest you in perhaps two chairs and $200?
What would you like to chairs and $200?
That's a great price. Why buy one chair, when you can have two chairs! Please pick up your
f*ing morgz
Okay
Iwata a new Apple mug. It's only $4999 and the cup pole is only- *Laughter*
These memes are great
Poppy Gloria is dead. There is no evidence. You have no evidence
You haven't uploaded this meme? You know, it's a new format, right?
Good evening. I'm Mary ham and welcome to meme review.
Oh, sorry, did I forget to say my intro? I'm Mary ham and hope you guys enjoyed this episode of LWIAY
Smash like and subscribe and I'll see you guys tomorrow because I'm doing all the shows here on
PewDiePie's channel.
Whaaat?? You never played youtuber simulator?
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not. Not convinced yet? Okay
I'll cut you a deal: the game is available for free and that's a great price